president trump has been kicked off of
twitter facebook
instagram snapchat and most other
internet platforms
a handful of oligarchs in silicon valley
have the power and the willingness to
censor the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
and conservatives let it happen i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show for now i guess
we're still on
for now i i feel as though we're on who
knows this might cut out at any minute
judging by the way social media are
going my favorite comment though
until then from friday is from user 115
who says
so when kamala harris raises money to
bail out criminals arrested in violent
riots
she is not inciting violence but when
trump says go home peacefully
and be responsible he is guilty yes
that's the way that it works that is the
way that the new standards work
and it's obviously the left's fault and
the left is clamping down
very hard right now and it is
legitimately threatening conservatives
ability to participate in our republic
however conservatives let it happen
conservatives
got this thing wrong from the beginning
this debate over free speech this debate
over censorship
this debate over all all manner of
of these questions and we're paying the
price
right now it's enough to drive a man
crazy make a guy want to relax if you do
want to relax i recommend first leaf
there is nothing like that friday
feeling and
i do not need to wait for that feeling
to kick in once a week because with
award-winning wine from first leaf any
day
can feel like friday first leaf is a
wine club that sends personalized
selections of wine
from top vineyards around the world
directly to you
because the only thing better than one
fantastic bottle of wine is a case of
award-winning wine
that shows up at your doorstep every
bottle handpicked by experts
with your exact preferences and palate
in mind for a unique combination of wine
you're guaranteed to love you know i've
been a member of other wine clubs
and they've all been pretty terrible so
i was skeptical of first leaf
first leaf is so smart and they give you
such a great product
they send you this the wine you try it
maybe they'll throw in one or two that
you don't think you like you try it
and then you rate with your preferences
and it gets more and more and more
tailored to you
really delicious stuff what are you
waiting for get that friday feeling like
i do any day with first leaf
you will get your first six bottles of
wine for 29.95 and free shipping
unbelievable deal
go to tryfirstleaf.com knowles six
bottles of wine for 29.95
and free shipping at tryfirstleaf.com
knowles
you know how much i like them go check
them out
big clamp down going on right now on
conservatives
on social media and it's important to
remember
the history that conservatives have had
with social media social media is the
reason that conservatives
were ascendant for much of the last 10
years
because before that we were shut out of
the
mainstream media even when we did manage
to get presidents elected they were
pretty liberal like george bush for
instance
or the other george bush social media
allowed conservatives to have a voice
when we had been shut out of the tv
networks when we've been shut out of the
newspapers
when we'd been shut out of hollywood the
the new media
gave us that kind of freedom and now
they're taking that freedom
away the clampdown that's going on right
now
is pretty significant in that
basically every prominent right winger
on social media
is losing lots and lots and lots of
followers
and when people complain about this it
seems sort of petty it seems like a
vanity contest
oh no you lost 30 000 twitter followers
boohoo for you i've got real problems
but i think actually that's sort of why
big tech is pursuing the strategy
because it sounds petty but it is
significant because if you take away
conservatives followers
all of a sudden conservatives no longer
have a voice and it doesn't just affect
some pundit and it doesn't just affect
some elected representative it affects
all conservatives who can't get
our voice out there that's what they're
betting on
jake tapper came out and he said i don't
know how my
how many twitter followers i've lost
because i don't pay attention to that
because i'm an adult
which is not true jake tapper has
bragged about his twitter followers in
the past
but that's not even the point tapper
hasn't lost any twitter followers
actually they've increased significantly
over the past few days whereas every
prominent conservative just about
has lost a lot up to and including the
president who lost his entire voice
on social media why does jake tapper
gain followers why is twitter
gaming their system to give him a larger
audience
because jake tapper is a submissive
vessel for the liberal establishment
so obviously they're going to reward him
and that he's going to continue to do
their bidding
whereas for conservatives we're not
going to do that and so twitter won't
either
twitter's ridiculous excuse for the the
clampdown
up to and including the man that the the
american people chose to be president at
least until january 20th
that guy's the duly elected president
twitter says
to clear up confusion about fluctuations
in follower accounts
fluctuations it's just going down by the
way it's not it's not like going up 50
000 and then
it's going down to clear up the
confusion in order to prevent spam
we regularly challenge accounts to
confirm details like email
and phone number until that info is
confirmed these accounts are not
included in follower accounts
that's obviously untrue right what
twitter is saying is
yeah look we think there this happens
every so often
um first of all we've never seen this
happen before and it's not happening
evenly it's only happening to
conservatives
but they're saying look what happens is
there are a lot of accounts we don't
know if they're real accounts or not
so we just take all of them out of the
follower accounts and then
as people confirm their details then all
of a sudden we add them back in
but if that were true then
all the conservatives i guess everybody
including liberals
their follower accounts would drop
dramatically and then slowly
increase as people confirm those details
that's not what's happening
the follower counts are steadily
decreasing but only for conservatives
and the only time it's not steady is
when you're talking about the president
of the united states
and associated accounts which have been
shut down
by some hipster-looking
radical oligarch in silicon valley named
jack dorsey who runs twitter
now you might say okay well you have no
right to use twitter's platform
twitter's a private company after all
sort of we'll get into that in a second
what what very often liberals and
squishy
conservatives fake conservatives have
said for in recent years is
make your own twitter oh come on you
have no right to use jack dorsey's
platform make your own twitter
yeah okay maybe dorsey and zuckerberg
and google have conquered the entire
public square and they now control
discourse in our republic but look
private company they can do whatever
they want
the problem with this are there are many
problems with this argument but the main
one the most obvious problem with this
argument is
you can't make your own twitter when
they say go make your own twitter
they won't let you make your own twitter
dan bongino did go make his own twitter
he called it parlor and he put it up
there
and then when twitter started censoring
conservatives a lot of conservatives
went over there
and then google and apple came out and
they said
we're not going to allow parlor on our
operating systems they're not going to
be in the app store so i guess if you've
got it installed good for you for now
but that's it
it's it's over google and apple control
99 of the mobile
operating system market share 99
if they kick you out of their stores
you're gone from cell phones
so they won't let you make your own
twitter okay well hold on you can still
access parlor through the web browser on
your phone
can't you sure you can't use the app but
you have no right
google and apple private companies sort
of so you have no right
to force your app into their app store
just go on the web browser
well that's what parlor said they would
do and guess what amazon web services
the web host
said that parlor's not allowed to even
have a website
if you go to parlor.com right now
chances are it will not load
now dan friend of the show
says that he's got a backup plan i hope
parlor is back online quickly
but how long before that web server
says no we're not going to host you
either this happened to
gab gab was this this alternative to
twitter that came up before parlor did
same thing kicked out of the app stores
kicked off their web hosting their
domain registrar godaddy they couldn't
even get the website
so all of a sudden we go from build your
own twitter come on just build your own
twitter
to come on build your own mobile
operating system
to build your own cell phone
to build your own web servers to build
your own domain registrar
to build your own internet
to i guess build your own government is
that the end of it oh wait a second
that's what we should have been doing
the whole time
we should have been engaging in politics
so that we could
wield political systems when the people
gave us power
and the fact that we did not do that on
the right
is the fault of conservatives
you know we stopped engaging in politics
and part of the reason for this is that
we took expressions like andrew
breitbart's favorite
famous expression when he said politics
is downstream of culture that's
obviously true
to a degree but we took an expression
like that
as an excuse not to engage in politics
we we took it as an excuse to say well
no
government it's always bad whenever
government does anything
and that's why you need to elect us so
that we won't do anything that you want
us to do
and we need to let big business run
roughshod over our culture
because we've we've exclusively got to
focus on the culture
and not on politics well look where
that's gotten us as if by the way there
was some
totally distinct line between culture
and politics
there obviously isn't culture affects
politics movies and tv and books and
art affects politics and politics
affects culture
we know that conservatives are willing
to admit that in our most candid moments
right when conservatives talk about the
disastrous policies of lbj and the great
society
all those welfare programs that trapped
people in generations of poverty
that was politics affecting culture
wasn't it thomas
writes about this all the time when he
says black americans were doing a whole
lot better before the great society
and the great society comes in and all
of a sudden they start doing much worse
what changed did the movies change i
guess a little bit did the art change
yeah sure
no what changed is the government policy
obviously
politics can shape culture
and and i think it's uh just a recourse
for people
who in a cowardly way don't want to
engage in the political system
who don't want to go in and say no big
tech you don't get to do that we're
going to break you up we're going to
break you up under antitrust laws
we're going to break you up because of
section 230 of the communications
decency act we're going to
break you up because of the fraud that
you've engaged in
this was so predictable this was so
predictable
they they had been signaling this for
months the minute that twitter
put a fact check on the president's
tweet
i thought it's only a matter of time
before they kick them off
the fact check was so ridiculous you
remember trump said we
i think we won the election and then
twitter says this claim is disputed
but they didn't really mean this claim
is disputed any claim on social media
could be disputed
and if a claim is disputed that means
that the counter claim is disputed too
but they didn't
when biden said we won the election they
didn't put a claim and said this claim
is disputed too obviously that claim was
disputed by trump
they had picked aside well okay
fair enough
questions of free speech and censorship
i suppose people can pick a side
but are we comfortable whatever you
think about whatever you think about the
election whatever you think about joe
biden whatever you think about donald
trump
ask yourself this are you really
comfortable
with a handful of radical left-wing
oligarchs in silicon valley billionaires
censoring the duly elected president i
did not elect
elect jack dorsey i did not elect mark
zuckerberg
and conservatives helped this happen
we've got to secure our politics a
little bit better we've got to secure
our homes too
you can do it with ring so much happens
at our front door
that is one thing that definitely has
not changed these days
it has never been more important to be
able to see what's there
and what's happening that is why it is
the perfect time to upgrade your
doorstep
with a ring video doorbell with ring you
can see and speak to whoever is at the
door from anywhere
right on your phone so you will never
miss a visitor let's say it's the guy
dropping off the package okay that's
good
maybe it's a guy dropping off a pizza oh
it's even better maybe let's say it's
your in-laws you stop where you are you
stand perfectly still you don't make a
peep
hopefully the the danger goes away and
you will know because
because of rain you will see exactly
what's going on they've got a ton of
other products as well right now
get a special offer on a ring welcome
kit at ring.com
knowles can a wlas comes with rings
video doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to upgrade your front
door and start your ring
experience that is ring dot com slash
knowles know w-l-e-s i love giving this
out as a gift
for my friends as a housewarming gift
also because it's not that expensive so
you get credit for giving a great gift
and you don't need to spend a lot
ring.com knowles
highly recommend ring you know how much
i love it go check ring out
conservatives are are largely
responsible for this
the left is i don't want a victim blame
the left is the aggressor here
conservatives let it happen how did we
let it happen well first of all
we had four years of the trump
administration and two years of unified
government
to to attack big tech bring them down to
size
we didn't do it do you know what we did
instead we called in the big tech
executives
and then the legislators got really good
sound bites
on tv yelling at the big tech executives
and they got
really good campaign commercials out of
it and then nothing happened
and then mark zuckerberg goes on tv and
he says yes
we have to do better oh we will yes oh
i'd
oh this was bad and we'll do better and
he's obviously lying
right he's obviously not telling the
truth because they didn't do better they
they got a lot worse
at least jack dorsey to his credit he's
never even pretended to care
jack dorsey it looks like hipster
rasputin with his beard
and he basically says i don't i don't
care about any of you guys
so we let that happen but the problem's
even deeper than that
and it's going to take a lot of soul
searching on the right
republicans have been shilling for big
business for decades now for decades
really starting i guess in the 70s but
really ramping up in the
80s and 90s and 2000s
conservatives have been shilling for
giant multinational corporations that
hate our culture that
ship our jobs overseas that don't give a
damn about this country
they've they've embraced this line build
your own twitter oh you can never
tell mark zuckerberg what to do he has
his sacred right to censor the president
it's his platform we shield we made an
idol
out of the free market and a boogeyman
out of big government
now am i saying that i don't like free
markets no i think the free market is
wonderful
i think it is one of the most brilliant
mechanisms ever devised and discovered
that is conducive to human flourishing
but it is not the moral arbiter in in my
political philosophy if
if the the free market if the invisible
hand of the free market and the morality
of the free market
tells me that i've got to let mark
zuckerberg censor the duly elected
president
then something's gone wrong in that
ideology same goes for big government
we made this huge boogeyman at a big
government
such that we ended up defending big
business
this is not what the the libertarians of
the 1960s talked about
the young conservative writer so rob
sharma posted a pretty funny meme the
other day
it was about how libertarians in the 60s
like barry goldwater said we're against
big everything we're against big
government we're against big monopolies
we're against big corporations
we realize that that kind of
unrestrained power
unrestrained there's the key is what is
the threat
to liberty some conservatives embraced
small government
there is no small government in america
there cannot be small
government you cannot govern
a nation that that spans not just an
entire continent but beyond a continent
to hawaii to alaska to the philippines
to guam
to all of our overseas interests do you
know that we have something called
africom have you heard of africom that's
the united states
african command last i checked we don't
have a state in africa
why do we have something called africom
because we have
a massive empire all over the world and
you might say well that's bad and we've
got to okay fine
all i'm saying is you don't govern that
country with small government
you can however govern that country with
limited government those are not the
same thing
limited government means you are
restraining the powers you don't let the
government do whatever it wants to do
capriciously arbitrarily well that's
good you got to rein that in
absolutely but don't just give a blank
check to big business
big business is just as capricious and
dangerous as big government
actually more so because there's no
accountability whatsoever
when zuckerberg and jack dorsey want to
censor the people's representative
at the same time that this was going on
the left was pursuing
a similar policy so so what the right
was doing was shrinking the legitimate
realm of politics
saying we can't we can't we actually
can't question
mark zuckerberg's behavior private
company business good
government bad at the same time the left
was going in
and also shrinking the realm of politics
in the in the
70s these awful screechy second wave
feminists
had this expression the personal is the
political
what they meant by that is that personal
behaviors the way a husband relates to
his wife
the way you relate to your kids the way
you educate your kids that's all open to
public scrutiny
while at the same time political
questions get taken out of politics so a
way to kind of bring this to earth and
give a good example is
abortion abortion highly controversial
political issue
obviously it's not addressed in the
constitution
the people have a right to debate and
decide do we want to permit
the killing of a million babies a year
in the womb or do we want to outlaw it
or do we want to outlaw it after 10
weeks or do we want to
outlaw after 20 weeks or do we whatever
right that's a political question
and then what the left said with roe
versus wade
is that they had the supreme court
invent a fictional constitutional right
to abortion
so while everything is becoming really
political they take a a very important
political question
remove it from the realm of politics so
in that way
the political realm always shrinking the
private realm grow growing
private realm taking over these
political questions and who sets the
rules
jack dorsey don jr to me
nearly he nearly got this exactly right
he observed something that was very true
and he just missed a couple words he
tweeted out
big tech has totally eliminated the
notion of free speech in america i think
a lot of people feel that way right now
it's not quite true but it's close
it's not that big tech has totally
eliminated the notion of free speech in
america
it's that big tech has totally
eliminated the american notion
of free speech let me ask you a question
is speech in america today freer
or less free than it was in the past
what do you think i think most people
right now most conservatives are going
to say
well speech is much less free we used to
be able to speak more freely
i'm not so sure about that is speech
today more or less free than it was in
the 50s
well for conservatives i guess it's less
free right
you know now if you wave an american
flag you can
you can be kicked out of school or if
you wear a make america great again hat
you will you can actually be suspended
from school
so it's less free but it's more free
today for communists
in the 1950s we had something called the
smith act
through which hundreds of communists
were prosecuted for their associations
for their beliefs for their free speech
in the 1950s you had people who
expressed communist political views
they were blacklisted they couldn't work
anymore
so so today speech is less frequent for
conservatives
more free for communists how about the
1790s
in the 1790s we had the alien and
sedition act
which meant that if you were to
criticize there were a lot of aspects to
this law but
if you were to criticize the government
wrongly if you were to lie and criticize
the government slander the government
you could be prosecuted for that so so
today
speech is much more free for dishonest
critics of the federal government
than it was in the 1790s but it's much
less
less free for conservatives go a little
further back go back even before the
declaration of independence go back to
the 1620s earliest days
of our country you know after the
pilgrims came here
there was a colonist by the name of
thomas morton thomas morton
was guilty of a heinous crime he wrote
poems
and sundry verses according to then
governor william bradford
that were lascivious they were verses
that were kind of like
sexy you know he wrote some like sort of
sexy poems
governor bradford marooned him on an
island and banished him to britain
do you think do you think that speech is
more free or less free today
for people who want to write sexy poems
uh probably more free for them
but less free for conservatives the
aspect of this social media purge of
this battle over
political correctness or woke-ism or big
tech tyranny or whatever
term you want to use everyone thinks
it's about free speech and
free speech and censorship it's not it's
not
at all times in all societies
some speech is permitted and some speech
is censored what it really is about is a
fight
between competing standards the
conservative the old standard
where you're allowed to wave the flag
but not the hammer and sickle
or the new standard where you're allowed
to wear the shake of our shirt but not
the maga hat
that's the competition right now that's
the debate
which standard are we going to live
under and the more we talk about
free speech absolutism we don't censor
any speech the more we
talk about that we're actually playing
into the left's hands
because they know there's got to be some
censorship
there's always got to be some censorship
you're not allowed to say whatever you
no society has ever permitted that least
of all the united states you can't
preach sedition you can't preach fraud
you can't preach fighting words you
can't preach threats
there's got to be some censorship which
standard is going to rain
which is going to rain right now it's
not looking good and it's
really not looking good for us here i
mean i as i referred to earlier
conservatives are being clamped down on
on social media
we are losing tens of thousands of our
audience by the day it's not because
people are unsubscribing
it's because big tech is limiting our
reach then when we try to go to other
platforms to get the message out so that
we can communicate with one another
they shut those down too how long before
they come after us
how long before they kick these shows
off of social media
it could be days this is i hope it's not
i hope we get to stay on
but it could be days they've already
tried shenanigans
and then how long before we're kicked
off of the internet
i don't know i we we've just got this is
going to go through a period of pain
right now
and we've got to be very careful one way
to do that is you have to subscribe
you know i usually don't pitch
subscribing to daily wire
super duper hard because you can listen
to the show on radio you can listen to
the show
on your podcast apps for free you can
watch some of it on youtube
i just don't know how for how much
longer that's going to be true
there very likely will come a time when
you need to subscribe it's the only way
that we can fight back and get a voice
out so please head on over to
dailywire.com become a member we'll be
right back with a lot more
we have got to ditch these shallow
slogans
like free speech absolutism or these
shallow ideas
like we don't want to censor anything we
do we i i want to censor threats
i think we should censor threats i think
we all agree with that i want to censor
uh fighting words i think we all agree
with that i want to censor fraud i think
we all agree with that
i want to censor sedition
i think most of us agree with that don't
we
i think so
i want to censor ideas that undermine
the very basis of the country the
philosophical basis of america
conservatives always agreed with that
now i don't know maybe it's more split
conservatives used to agree with the
idea that we shouldn't be able to
desecrate the american flag because it's
an incoherent act
you're not allowed to claim first
amendment protections
as your uh justification for burning the
american flag
which is a symbol of the entire country
including your first amendment
protections
doesn't make sense in recent years we've
taken a much more permissive stance
what's it gotten us
not not very far not very far big
tech used this
excuse of the capital riot to clamp down
on us
if the riot had not happened i think
they would have eventually found
something else
i think they've been looking for an
excuse for a long time
and they've done it to some people right
they they kick alex jones off the
internet
and no one really says boo some of us
did i mean i i at the time i said it was
a very bad thing
but most people didn't care he's alex
jones he's that crazy guy
who talks about how they're turning the
frickin frogs gay remember that
which you know it's funny of all the
things that alex jones has said some of
which are a little
a little more out there than others the
thing about the gay frogs
actually turned out to be true i looked
it up one day
there actually there was some study i
think was between yale and the epa that
some chemicals in the water had been
making frogs hermaphroditic so actually
it's not that they were turning the
freaking frogs gay they were turning
them trans
they were alex jones was actually too
reserved
in his in his take on things neither
here nor there very few people spoke
after alex jones now they're taking off
the president
that's quite a even the new york times
which has gone so insane even kevin
roose the technology columnist at the
new york times
published a column they said man this is
bad this is
at least very scary that this amount of
power
resides in the hands of
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg and
these unaccountable
billionaires but they're going to keep
using this they're going to use the
capitol hill riot
as the excuse to shut us all up and
you're going to have squishy fake
republicans
guys like mitt romney or arnold
schwarzenegger come out remember arnold
schwarzenegger was governor of
california
he was basically governed like a
democrat he wasn't wasn't particularly
strong
they're going to come out and use any
manner of hyperbole
to cram this narrative down our throats
schwarzenegger just came out he posted a
video comparing the capitol hill riot
to the nazis in kristallnacht
i grew up in austria i'm very aware of
crystal nacht
or the night of broken glass it was a
night of rampage against the jews
carried out in 1938
by the nazi equivalent of the proud boys
wednesday was the day of broken glass
right here in the united states
the broken glass was in the windows of
the united states capital
but the mob did not just shatter the
windows of the capital
they shattered the ideals we took for
granted
they did not just break down the doors
of the building that housed
american democracy they trampled the
very principles
in which our country was founded
is that so arnold
last i checked uh during kristallnacht
rioters destroyed 267 synagogues
throughout germany austria and the
sudetenland
they murdered at least 91 jews very
likely
many more 7 000 jewish businesses were
damaged
or destroyed and thirty thousand jewish
men were arrested
and sent to concentration camps
and during the capitol hill riot one of
the pro-trump
rioters ashley babbitt was shot and
killed by police
and a police officer sadly died
and a
rioter took took photos messing up nancy
pelosi's
office and some other fellow
took a podium and posed for funny
pictures with a podium
both bad things not saying that either
of those events were
crystal knocked or the capital right i'm
not not defending either either of those
events
not on the same level very different uh
torching hundreds of synagogues
deporting
tens of thousands of people killing lots
and lots of people
damaging seven thousand businesses
different very different
not every bad thing is the holocaust
this should be emblazoned on
every uh debate stage
on every camera that films a political
commentator or a politician
i wish people would take this to heart
not every bad thing is the holocaust
idiots compare bad things to the
holocaust
all the time because they don't have any
other historical perspective
so the two the two things you'll hear
everything is either the holocaust or
the fall of rome
i suppose some things are like the
holocaust in the fall of rome in some
ways
but very few there are other historical
events
and you know schwarzenegger was not
alone
in in this kind of hyperbole aoc
everyone's favorite darling socialist
congresswoman
went on television and said look you
think
that you know it was a demonstrator who
died and then a police officer died
later from wounds and apparently some
other medical condition but it's sort of
unclear
no wasn't that and then i think three
other people just like happened to be
around the
protest and had heart attacks things
like that obviously not from the
violence
uh but regardless say i don't know five
five people
four of whom were demonstrators three of
whom
then died from their own medical
emergencies okay
very very sad right
aoc took that and somehow read that as
uh nearly half of congress almost dying
well you know i absolutely believe that
impeachment should be scheduled for
several reasons
several reasons one of course our main
priority is to ensure the removal
of donald trump as president of the
united states every minute and every
hour that he is in office represents a
clear and present
danger not just to the united states
congress but frankly to the country but
in addition to removal
we're also talking about complete
barring
of the president or rather of donald
trump from running for office
ever again and in addition to that the
potential
ability to prevent pardoning himself
from
those charges that he was impeached for
we came close to half of the house
nearly dying
on wednesday i don't
think that we did i don't
i don't think nearly half of the house
almost died i don't think
nearly any member of the house almost
died i don't think any member of the
house
was even injured that's just
a complete lie it's just completely made
up
why does aoc aoc is very good at this
you might call it the big lie she aoc is
very good
that's a phrase by the way that you're
going to be hearing a lot of left
wingers now referring to
like for instance because joe biden has
been comparing republican politicians
to joseph goebbels because joe biden is
a liar and an idiot
and a cynic and a hack and a very very
very bad man and so they're gonna
they're all gonna call everyone nazis
and then
aoc is going to come out and lie and say
oh half the members of congress almost
died
not uh none of them the
the last time that members of congress
almost died like that
was not the capitol hill riot it was
2017 when a bernie bro shot up the
congressional baseball game
and very nearly killed steve scalise
and other members of congress steve
scalise really was close to death but
other guys
rand paul was hiding out right rand paul
could have been hit
other people too that that story
disappeared from the news
you didn't hear about the nazi democrats
and
all these sorts of things because that
was not
helpful to their narrative so even
though the congressional baseball game
shooting
was much much much much much more
dangerous to members of congress
that one disappeared and you didn't see
the hand ringing
and all of these sorts of hysterical
calls
for for instance the impeachment of the
president why do they want to impeach
the president
he's going to leave office in what eight
days or something 10 days
why do you want to impeach him because
they don't want him to be able to run
for office again why don't they want him
to run for office again
if this guy's such a failed president he
never would have a chance right
wrong they are not doing this
because they believe that donald trump
is very very weak
and joe biden is very very popular quite
the opposite
they are not shutting up every
conservative on social media
and trying to legally bar the president
from running for office again
because they think that he could never
get a lot of votes
that he could never win that he's not
popular that's not it at all
raises a lot a lot of eyebrows
moreover if we're told that now because
president trump said hey
attend a rally in dc to support me and
the make america great again movement
but don't become violent be very
peaceful go home
if you're getting violent don't be
violent if we're told that that is
an incitement to violence that is worthy
of impeachment
what do we make of kamala harris who
actively encouraged the blm riots that
burned down cities coast to coast
and killed dozens of people over the
summer i know that there are protests
still happening
in major cities across the united states
i'm just not seeing the reporting on it
that i
that i had that's right for the first
few weeks um but they're not
they're not gonna stop and that's
they're not this is a movement i'm
telling you
they're not gonna stop and and everyone
beware
because they're not gonna stop it is
gonna they're not gonna stop before
election day in november and they're not
gonna stop after election day
and that should be everyone should take
note of that on both levels that this
isn't they're not gonna let up and they
should not and we should not
they're not going to let up and they
should not and we should not
they had been burning cities and burning
businesses
and killing people all around the
country to achieve a political end
and kamala harris encouraged the
equivalent would be if mike pence came
out
after the capital let's say for instance
that the capitol hill riot was much
deadlier than it was
let's say that they burned down i don't
know the capitol building or they burned
down some other government buildings or
they killed dozens of people
and then the next day mike pence came
out and instead of condemning it like
all the republicans did including the
president
let's say pence came out and he said hey
they're not going to stop
those guys at the cat they're not going
to stop nor should they stop
and we shouldn't stop either they're
never gonna stop so give us power
could you imagine no you can't imagine
is republicans don't do that sort of
thing
but the left does and they've somehow
because they've just taken over the
whole culture and they've taken over the
politics
and they've taken over the language that
we use they have somehow convinced us
that the capitol hill riot bad as it was
was worse
than months and months of blm death and
destruction across the country
and the apparently elected
vice president-elect kamala harris
encouraging it kamala harris when people
got arrested
for burning down minnesota do you know
what do you know what she did
she posted a fundraising link to to
their bail fund
some of that money was used to bail out
a child rapist
a guy who raped an eight-year-old girl
she's apparently going to be the vice
president
imagine that and we're hand ringing
about oh donald trump
well he should have condemned the
violence
eight minutes prior he waited five
minutes too long
give me a break goodness gracious people
somehow some people are still sort of
listening to mitt romney
well he lectures all of us romney
marched with these with these guys blm
and antifa
he marched with them well no he only
marched with the
with the peaceful blm protesters not the
violent blm
and antifa rioters
first of all didn't see a whole lot of a
difference
if you look at the rubble of the cities
the day after but do you think that that
subtle distinction is
is being appreciated on the right
between the 99.999
of peaceful demonstrators and the .001
percent of people who stole the podium
and messed up nancy pelosi's desk
i don't think so not the only ones
slate former cnn contributors
other prominent leftists current cnn
anchors
all promoting violence all promoting
violence
these are the blm stuff and the capitol
hill stuff they are analogous
except uh in one way two ways
one blm was much deadlier
much more ruinous caused much more
damage to businesses and
people's lives but two blm
got something out of it blm got
political concessions out of it
blm helped shape the democratic party
agenda on
defunding the police talk about you know
attacking the heart of our democracy
law and order is is the heart of our
democracy right the the police are the
law enforcement agency
that go in and defend the american
system
that seems like a threat to me the left
got something out of it the right
didn't get anything out of the misguided
and very very bad capitol hill riot
slate comes out quote
non-violence is an important tool for
protests
but so is violence they tweeted that out
june 4th 2020 this was during blm
non-violence is an important tool for
protests but so is violence
imagine if the daily wire the next day
tweeted out you know non-violence is
good for the make america great again
movement
but violence is important too should
have taken a few more podiums
should have smashed a few more windows
maybe worse
that would be the equivalent slate still
has its twitter account
if the daily wire ever tweeted anything
like that i assure you not only would
our social media accounts be gone
our web hosting would be gone too the
president tweets out be peaceful they
take away his twitter account
and facebook access other leftist cnn's
rizza aslan who is
uh actually a cannibal he's actually
eaten human brains uh this is the kind
of person they put on cnn
he tweets that quote if they even try to
replace rbg we burn the entire
effing thing down
i don't need to point out what would
happen if a right winger said something
similar
emmett macfarlane who's some blue
checkmark on the left i don't even know
what he does
burn congress down before letting trump
try to appoint anyone to the supreme
court
laura bassett same thing if mcconnell
jams someone through which he will there
will be riots okay well there were i
guess
uh charlotte climber who is this
transgender fellow
who is very vocal and left-wing
we're now walking to mitch mcconnell's
house to protest so now actually going
to threaten the guy's house
obviously we chris cuomo i guess is
probably the greatest example of this
cuomo openly on national television if
you can call cnn national television
it's mostly
just an airport intercom system but
theoretically
it's a big tv network goes out and and
defends violent protests
now too many see the protests as the
problem
no the problem is what forced your
fellow citizens
to take to the streets persistent and
poisonous
inequities and injustice and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful as we have noted before the
first amendment is where it says that
protests are supposed to be peaceful
because you have the right to peaceably
assemble but i actually can't believe
i'm saying this
i want to defend chris cuomo for a
second
not defend the point he's actually
making but to defend
the thinking behind the point that he's
making
well we're all getting blue in the face
yelling about the double standards here
we are failing to acknowledge that this
is
about standards getting back to what we
were talking about earlier in the show
this is not about free speech this is
not
about censorship all societies permit
some amount of speech
and they all enforce some degree of
censorship
this has been true everywhere throughout
the entire history of the world
and it has been true in the united
states maybe particularly in the united
states
eriopogitica which is the greatest
defense of free speech in the english
language
says that we shouldn't give free speech
to catholics and milton actually makes
some good arguments for it
john locke in his letter on toleration
says we shouldn't tolerate atheists
and he makes some good arguments for it
even the most
robust liberal defenses of free speech
acknowledged that there were limits in
censorship what the left is saying
is that if you go out and you
you protest and becomes violent and use
loot gucci stores
in the name of blm that is a good thing
and we will tolerate that
but if you go out and wave the american
flag and let's say it becomes
somewhat violent we will not tolerate
that
we will give blm spots at the democratic
national convention
and we will put the mega protesters in
jail
and the right and certainly the writers
are going to jail
those are different standards but we've
always had standards
in the 1950s if you went out and held a
big protest
even a peaceful protest for communism
you
you could be prosecuted for that as well
you should be
frankly if we were a little tougher on
communism today we might not be in the
position that we're in
and if you went out then and waved an
america flag or you said make america
great again you'd be totally fine
we had standards then too we will always
have standards and what what
conservatives have
unfortunately done is we've come out and
we've said
hey i i support all sorts of speech
i don't want any standards at all say
whatever words you want on television
oh drag queen story hour it's a blessing
of liberty oh it's wonderful
i would never because if i tell
you that you're not allowed to host a
drag queen story hour and have
transvestites twerk for toddlers well
then you
might tell me that i can't go to church
and so we're all just going to throw up
our hands
because they're all the same right no no
good to go to church bad to go to dragon
queen story hour
we should encourage people to go to
church or you know practice their
religion
generally good religion though not like
uh
satanism i don't think we should promote
satanism don't think we should promote
uh secular liberalism that's a pretty
weird religion there was just a video
that went around a new york post sent it
out
of this this white woman forcing her
children to kneel down and pray
to black women actually to make an idol
out of black women actually to objectify
black women
which is kind of ironic she doesn't
think she's doing that i just thought
man secular liberalism that is a weird
religion
that is one of the strangest religions
i've ever seen but you want to promote
the good you want to discourage the bad
we've always understood this in america
conservatives libertarians
liberals all understood this well
liberals and progressives still
understand this
they still understand you got to promote
some things you got to discourage other
things
just they flip the standards right now
there's a tweet went up on january 7th
from the chinese embassy in the united
states it says quote study shows the
population change in northwest china's
zhengzhang uighur autonomous region
involves the overall
improvement in population quality oh man
an increasing number of youths chose to
spend more time and energy on personal
development
population change and population
improvement this is an open call by an
enemy nation
for genocide open promotion of genocide
on twitter
totally fine that's okay according to
the new standards
but the duly elected sitting president
of the united states
calling for peace not permitted on
twitter
or are we going to say well i can't take
a side we can't promote one over the
other
we need to support every single view
viewpoint neutrality
we're going to say that it doesn't seem
to be working well in practice
of racial caste systems joe biden is
proposing one
president-elect joe biden says
his priority when he gets into office is
going to be
to support black
businesses and latino businesses and all
sorts of businesses but
but not white businesses our focus will
be on small businesses on main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic
hardships through no fall of their own
our priority will be black latino asian
and native american-owned small
businesses women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
that's a new standard that's a new stamp
the older standard
which we've had for you know at least
about 50 years at least
at least half a century in this country
is we're not going to push racial
preferences
we're going to let people stand on their
own we're not going to prioritize race
now we've got a new standard which is we
are going to prioritize race
certain races are going to get
preferences certain races are not pretty
ugly stuff to me
that's the future unless you stand up
for a standard of your own i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles show see
you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show